So last time we started to talk about or
uh we actually got uh we almost finished
talking about safety and livveness. Uh
and I wanted to just wrap up the
discussion of of safety and livveness
properties from last time.
Uh so so let's recap what we said before
about that. So um so a safety property
we had we we distinguish between between
safety and livveness properties.
A safety property is one that uh
colloquially it says uh something bad
never happens.
And a characteristic of these properties
is that they can't
or excuse me that they can
be violated
in a finite execution.
So examples of safety properties are all
of the delivery guarantees that we've
talked about so far.
So FIFO and FIFO delivery, causal
delivery, totally ordered delivery,
these these properties are all safety
properties.
uh and the reason for that is that you
could
in a finite execution violate all these
properties. So you could draw a line
here making this a finite execution and
then there's a you can see that there's
a violation of that property. Uh on
aliveness property on the other hand
is one that says something good
eventually happens.
And aliveness property
cannot
be violated
in a finite execution.
And the reason for that is that uh in a
livveness property it's going to be
something where
if it hasn't uh been satisfied in a
finite execution you can say it's uh
it's just it just hasn't been satisfied
yet. Uh so we gave an example of that
last time. Uh and the example of
aliveness property we had was uh
something like the system eventually
responds to a client request. So if you
had a client and a system and the client
makes a request, right, and then some
time goes by.
This is not to say that the the system
is never going to respond to the
request, right? So the property
uh that the system eventually responds
to every client request uh has not been
violated yet. Um, so livveness
properties don't have finite counter
examples. I can't draw a picture of a
finite execution that violates this
property. Um, so I think one thing I
started to talk about briefly last time
was that um, the trouble is that you
really need both livveness and safety
properties. And I say the trouble
because that makes reasoning harder,
right? If we only had to reason about
about safety properties uh or livveness
properties, uh then that would be
easier. But we we really need both. And
so here's why.
Let's say I asked you to implement a
protocol that satisfies say FIFO
delivery and I told you you didn't need
to worry about livveness at all. Uh
well, what could you do, right? If I
said you only needed the the property of
FIFO delivery, which is a safety
property, uh we talked about this a
couple days ago. So, you can build a
system that just drops or ignores every
message, right?
Uh
and so on.
Does it satisfy FIFO? It does actually
because you're never doing the bad
thing, right? So
FIFO just says that a bad thing never
happens. This satisfies FIFO.
uh messages never get delivered in the
wrong order because they don't get
delivered at all. Right? So, good job.
You get an A. Um so, safety properties
by themselves are useless. Um uh but it
turns out that livveness by itself is
also useless. Uh and we'll talk about
that more later on uh when we talk about
the cap theorem. Uh by the way,
somebody's asking on Twitch if they can
ask a question. Yes, please ask your
question. Uh, I can't guarantee that
I'll answer it, but you should ask it
for sure. Um, all right. So, um, have we
talked about any properties yet that are
that are livveness properties? Uh, other
than this, um, system eventually
responds to every request thing that I
that I just made up. Have we talked
about any livveness properties?
Anyone want to take a stab at that?
Yeah, absolutely. Reliable delivery is
an example.
So, we we talked about it. We haven't
defined it formally yet. uh but we've
we've talked about it. So let's actually
give a definition to reliable delivery.
Um so how do we define this varies
depending on who you ask. Um but okay so
here's one definition
We'll say this.
Let P1 be a process
that sends a message
M
to process P2.
If neither
P1
nor P2
crashes,
then
P2
eventually
delivers M.
Sometimes you see people add another
piece to this definition as well. Uh
they'll say uh if neither P1 nor P2
crashes and not all messages are lost.
Um so this is kind of interesting,
right? Why would people define this in
different ways? Uh and that actually
leads us into the topic of fault models
uh which we're going to talk about uh in
a little while. Um but anyway, I'm I'm
claiming that that reliable delivery is
a livveness property.
Why is it aliveness property? Um well,
it says that something good eventually
happens, right? Eventually M gets
delivered. Um but furthermore, we can
tell that it's not a safety property. Uh
right, because it can't be violated uh
in a finite execution. Uh uh we don't um
we don't have a finite counter example
for it or we can't draw a picture of a
finite execution that violates this
reliable delivery property.
So since all properties that we care
about are either safety properties or
live livveness properties or a
combination of both and we know it's not
safety um then we know it has to be a
livveness property. Um so this is this
is the first livveness property
that we've uh formally defined I think
questions about that
Okay. So, we're going to talk about
fault models. Um, so
this is a new topic
that I've kind of been hinting for a
couple of days that we'll get to.
So when you're designing a system, you
need to start by making certain
assumptions about the environment in
which that system operates. Right? So in
particular, if you're building uh if
you're trying to build a fault tolerant
system, if you're trying to design a
fault tolerant system, then you need to
have some sort of an idea about what
kind of faults may occur, right? So that
you know what kind of faults you need to
tolerate. It doesn't mean anything to
say that your system is is fault
tolerant if you don't have a definition
of what it is to be a fault.
So we need some way of defining and
classifying faults and putting them in
categories. Um and a fault model is
something that tells you which
categories of faults can occur so that
you know which ones you need to worry
about.
So, if you think back to um day one or
day two of class, um
day two for people who were in the class
at UCSC, I guess, day one for people who
were watching on Twitch, um we had this
situation with two machines, right,
where where machine one wants to ask
machine two a question uh and and get a
response. So, machine one is asking what
the value of x is and uh machine two is
hopefully answering. We talked about a
bunch of different ways in which this
could go wrong. Um so let's quickly uh
remind ourselves what what some of those
ways were. So
um message from
M1 to M2 could get lost.
Um,
message from M1 to M2 is slow.
M2 crashes.
Um,
M2 is slow.
Um and then in the other direction, uh
some of the same things could happen,
right? Um the message from M2 to M1
could be slow or the message from M2 to
M1 could get lost, right? Um so that's
like five and six, right?
And then one that uh that we very
briefly also discussed um is uh M2 lies
right
or messages get corrupted.
Um so let's try to classify all these
faults into categories.
Um so for this first one um uh when a
message from M1 to M2 gets lost um or
when a message from M2 to M1 gets lost
uh let's call that an omission fault. So
a message getting lost is called an
omission fault.
What about a message being slow?
What would you call that?
So there's different choices for this.
Um, sometimes people call that a
performance fault. Um, I'm going to call
that a timing fault.
Um,
same one for um, uh, the message from M2
to M1 being slow.
Um, how about number three? Uh, where M2
crashes? Um, well, this one is what we
call a crash fault.
Um, number four, this is another timing
fault. This would be where the the
machine is being slow rather than the
the network being slow. Or another way
to say that is that it's um the process
being slow rather than the channel being
slow. Um but we'll we'll put it in that
same category of timing faults.
Um so number five here, slowness here is
another timing fault. Uh message being
lost here, this is another omission
fault.
Um so let's put those down
um and and give uh some informal
definitions for those. So
types of faults.
So
omission fault
a message is lost.
timing fault.
Uh,
a message
or
process
is slow.
This is an informal definition. I'm I'm
intentionally not defining like what it
means for something to be slow. Uh and
we'll come back to that. Uh and then we
said a crash fault.
A process crashes.
So that I think covers
everything on this picture um except for
one. Um so which uh which did I not uh
which did I not cover here in that
categorization of faults
number seven
being evil. Right.
So um so we briefly talked about that on
the first day of class actually. So what
what kind of fault is that?
Byzantine fault.
Good.
Um,
I'm going to say malicious
or
arbitrary behavior.
All right. So, that's at least four
different kinds of faults that we have.
Omission faults,
uh, timing faults, crash faults,
Byzantine faults. Um, this is a kind of
classic way of categorizing faults. Um,
why is it called Byzantine? Somebody
asked in chat. Um, uh, historical
reasons. Um uh so there's a there's
there's a a a famous paper uh called the
Byzantine general's problem uh from
which this uh which popularized this
term Byzantine faults. Um but now the
next obvious question is why was the
paper called the Byzantine general's
problem? Um and I I don't think the
answer is particularly interesting. Um I
I think um the author Leslie Lamport was
just looking for uh a catchy name that
um so the we'll talk more about this
later, but um uh the idea is that there
are these these these two generals with
their armies that are attempting to
communicate and he didn't uh he didn't
want to use the name of any uh I guess
extant country um because uh he didn't
want that to um
uh he didn't he didn't want do that. So,
um, so he picked this name Byzantine
and, uh, and I guess it stuck.
Um,
so
this is a classic way of categorizing
faults. Um, and this is a taxonomy of
faults that distributed systems people
have been using um, since at least the
'9s. Um
so let's try and um and define these
types of faults uh just a little bit
more precisely and try to create a
hierarchy of them as well. So
at the bottom of the hierarchy um we'll
say are crash faults.
Uh so by the way somebody just uh posted
a link to the the two generals problem.
Um, we're actually going to be talking
about the two generals problem in a
little while. Um, so the the the
Byzantine generals problem uh is uh um
distinct but related to but distinct
from the two generals problem. Um okay.
So let's let's talk about uh
the um like at the kind of bottom of the
fault hierarchy um are crash faults. So
let's talk about those first.
So in a crash fault
um we say a process fails by halting.
And that means it stops sending or
receiving any messages.
Now, processes can have uh internal
events as well as sends and receives,
right?
So, you might ask, well, uh if it
stopped sending and receiving messages,
is it still allowed to have internal
events even though it crashed? And well,
I suppose the answer is yes, but it
doesn't really matter, right? Because if
it can't send or receive any messages,
then it can't communicate with other
processes anyway. So it uh it can't have
an effect on the behavior of the system
outside itself anyway. So it might as
well not be having any internal events
because uh its behavior doesn't matter
to the behavior of the rest of the
system. So that's a crash fault.
um in an omission fault. That's kind of
the next step up in the hierarchy. And
we'll talk about why these are in this
hierarchy in a minute.
Um
this is when a message is lost.
And you could think of this as a process
uh failing to send or receive a message.
in a timing fault.
We say a process responds
too late.
So the way that some people define
timing fault is they say a timing fault
is when a process responds too late or
too early. Um so so this is kind of
interesting. Um and that would be
something that that would be a way that
you might define timing faults let's say
at the hardware level. Um, for us, um,
it's more common to have the kind of
timing fault where something is slow and
we want it to be fast where rather than
than to have the kind where something is
fast and we want it to be slow. Uh, for
the most part though, it's kind of a
moot point because we're not going to be
discussing timing faults very much at
all in this course. And the reason why
is because we're mostly going to be
talking about the asynchronous network
model uh where there are no uh
guarantees on the length of time that a
message can take. So if there is no
guarantee on the length of time that
messages can take, then by definition we
can't really have timing faults uh
because there were no guarantees in the
first place that were supposed to be
abided by. Um, so I'm including it here
because it's sometimes included in the
literature on these things, but for the
most part, we're not going to be talking
about timing faults.
Um, and then finally, in a Byzantine
fault,
um,
process
behaves
in an arbitrary
or even malicious way.
So these are slightly more rigorous
definitions than I had on the on the
last piece of paper. So these are the
types of faults we're interested in. Um
let's just go ahead and cross out timing
fault because that's not really going to
be uh
part of our fault model for the most
part. So, we're mostly just going to be
thinking about these these three kinds
of faults. And even then, we're going to
be spending most of our time talking
about these two, crash faults and
omission faults.
So,
why did they go in this order? Why am I
putting them in this hierarchy? Um, so
let's talk about that. So, let's say
that we have some protocol uh some set
of rules by which processes send and
receive messages and call it protocol X.
And let's say that protocol X tolerates
crash faults.
And let's say that we have some other
protocol, call it protocol Y, that
implements the same behavior. Um, but
protocol Y tolerates omission faults.
Okay. So my question for you is
does protocol Y also tolerate crash
faults? If we say it tolerates omission
faults, does it also have to tolerate
crash faults? What do you think?
And why?
Okay. Uh okay. So one answer is yeah. So
since omission faults are higher on the
hierarchy, they should be able to handle
crash faults. But okay, but why why are
omission faults higher on the hierarchy?
So somebody says, yeah, okay, because a
process crashing is similar to the
message not being received indefinitely.
Yeah. So crash faults can be thought of
as a special case of omission faults.
where all the messages to and from a
particular process get lost.
Right? So if a process crashes
um if a process is going along having
events and then it crashes uh from that
point onward
uh every message sent and every message
received that would have happened you
can say well that that's uh an omission
fault. So crash faults can be thought of
as a special case of omission faults. So
a protocol that tolerates omission
faults uh also has to tolerate crash
faults. Um so um the the way that I
wrote it on this page when I said crash
faults are at the top of the hierarchy.
I guess what I meant was uh they were at
the bottom of the hierarchy. They were
at the top of the page because they were
the most fundamental one that I that I
wanted to talk about first or the uh the
kind of the the first one that you
wanted to try that you want to try to uh
be tolerant of. Um so we can draw a
picture um illustrating how these
categories of faults are nested. Um so
crash faults
go here
and omission faults
go here. Um and again why is this the
case? Um, it's because
crash faults
are the special case
of omission faults where all
messages is
uh to and from
a process
get lost after some point.
So we say crash faults are a proper
subset of omission faults.
Okay. So if we wanted to put timing
faults on this picture, uh then we could
um we could say
something like this.
So why is that? Why are timing faults uh
a super set of of omission faults here?
Um it's because omission faults are the
special case of timing faults where
messages are infinitely slow. So a
timing fault is when a message or or a
process is too slow. Omission faults are
the special case of that where messages
are infinitely slow. So a protocol that
tolerates timing faults also tolerates
omission faults. Um and since we just
said that crash faults are a subset of
omission faults, it has to tolerate
those too. So timing faults will
encompass both of those. That having
been said, um we aren't really going to
talk much about timing faults.
Um and though then finally let's say
that we have a protocol that tolerates
by Byzantine faults. So remember a
Byzantine fault is when a process
behaves in an arbitrary or a malicious
way. Um oh so somebody just wanted to
see this definition. Um so this is
actually um uh this isn't the definition
of of crash faults but it's a fact about
crash faults. So we say crash faults are
the special case of omission faults
where all messages to or from a process
get lost after some point. Uh the
definition
is what I put here.
A crash fault is just when a process
fails by halting.
Okay. So what about Byzantine faults? Uh
so if we have some other protocol that
tolerates Byzantine faults,
um does it have to also tolerate all
these other kinds of faults?
If I claim that the process or if I
claim that the protocol is uh is
Byzantine fault tolerant, does it have
to be tolerant of these other kinds of
faults as well?
So some folks are saying uh saying no.
Um so I would argue that it does
actually. So the thing about a Byzantine
fault is that the faulty process can do
anything it wants including mimicking
the fault behaviors that you get with
these other kinds of faults.
Um, so
a process that wanted to exhibit
Byzantine behavior, uh, could say, "I'm
going to pretend to crash now." And then
from that point onward, it, uh, other
processes would think it had crashed
because it wouldn't be sending any
messages or wouldn't be responding to
any messages. Or, um, a process
exhibiting Byzantine behavior could say,
"I'm just not going to selectively not
send some messages." And then that would
look like an omission fault to the rest
of the system. Um, so these are all
considered a subset of Byzantine faults.
So timing faults are a subset of
Byzantine faults.
Omission faults are a subset of timing
faults. Crash faults are a subset of
omission faults. Um
questions about this?
There's a paper um that I want to refer
you to. Uh the paper is actually uh not
uh specifically about fault models, but
it has a nice uh illustration of the
taxonomy of fault models in it. So I'm
going to point you at it anyway. Um the
paper is called
atomic broadcast
from simple
message diffusion
to Byzantine agreement.
and this paper is from uh 1994.
So I can't remember if this exact figure
is in that paper but something a lot
like it is.
Okay.
So
let's go back to our to our
example of protocol X and protocol Y
where we said uh protocol X uh tolerates
crash faults
and protocol Y tolerates omission
faults.
So, which of these would you say is more
fault tolerant, X or Y?
Yeah. Why is right? because it tolerates
all the faults that X does plus more.
Um, and which of X or Y do you think is
going to be more complicated and
expensive to implement?
Yeah. Also, why right? Because in
general, the larger the class
of faults that a protocol tolerates, the
more complicated and expensive it's
going to be to implement.
Byzantine fault tolerance is the most
complicated and most expensive of all.
Uh so this is the classic picture that
you'll see if you go and look at the
literature on fault tolerance. Um
so the only thing that's that we're
going to do differently uh is that for
the most part we're not going to talk
too much about timing faults.
Um, so the reason for that is
all bugs have to be relative to a
specification. And so if we had a
specification that said that messages
couldn't take more than a certain amount
of time to be delivered, then we could
have timing faults. But we don't have a
specification like that when we're in
the async network model. uh because
remember an asynchronous network is one
where there's no n such that no message
takes longer than n units of time to be
delivered. So messages can be
arbitrarily slow. So timing faults are
sort of not applicable in our world of
the asynchronous network model. Um so
for us um the picture is kind of just
going to look
more like this.
So our hierarchy is going to be like
crash faults, omission faults, Byzantine
faults.
Um,
so
it should be pointed out that this
particular hierarchy of faults is not
the only one that we could use and we
could actually subdivide some of these
classes of faults further.
Um, so for instance, take Byzantine
faults. Some Byzantine faults are going
to be easier to deal with than others.
What would be an example of a of a
Byzantine fault that might be relatively
easy to deal with?
And I'm going to uh draw a cleaner
version of this same picture.
And so while I'm doing that, uh can you
think of what a a Byzantine fault might
be that would be relatively easy to deal
with?
Great. Yeah. So, some people have made a
couple of suggestions. Uh, so messages
getting duplicated or uh when the
receiver gets the wrong message. Yeah.
So, a message that gets altered is a
Byzantine fault. Um but some kinds of
alterations are detectable
uh using techniques like check sums or
error correcting codes. So if you
receive a message and you can tell that
it's been corrupted, then maybe that's
not so bad, right? Um what's worse is
when the message is so cleverly
corrupted that the authentication
technique that you're using fails to
detect the corruption, right? Uh so so
really we could distinguish between the
kinds of corrupted messages that we can
detect and those that that we can't
necessarily detect. So we can say uh
authentication detectable
authentication detectable Byzantine
faults and then that falls inside this
larger class of
uh
Byzantine faults.
So, authentication detectable Byzantine
faults are a subset of Byzantine faults.
What can you do when you detect that a
message has been corrupted?
Any ideas?
Yeah, you just discard it. You drop it
on the floor or ignore it. So basically
if you have some kind of authentication
technique then you can downgrade certain
kinds of Byzantine faults to omission
faults. If the message is corrupted then
it's as though it never happened. So
then it's an then it's just an omission
fault instead of being a Byzantine
fault.
So the particular details of this uh
these authentication techniques are
outside of the scope of this class. Uh
but if you want to know more about that,
maybe take a security class or talk to
my colleague Owen Arden about that.
Okay, so now that we have all of these
different nested classes of faults
defined, uh we can maybe a little bit
more formally say what a fault model is.
So a fault model
is a specification
that
specifies
what kinds of faults
A system
may exhibit.
And this defines
what kinds of faults
are to be tolerated by the system.
So
each of these kinds of faults
corresponds to a fault model. Uh if
you're assuming that you're working with
the crash model, then your system has to
be tolerant of crash faults.
If you're assuming the omission fault
model, then what kind of to faults do
you have to be tolerant of? You have to
be tolerant of omission faults and also
crash faults because those are included
in omission faults. And if you're
assuming the Byzantine fault model, you
have to be tolerant of Byzantine faults,
which implies that you have to be
tolerant of all these other kinds of
faults. Um so fault models are nested
just like these classes of faults are.
And as you move outward in this circle
uh the fault models uh get uh um more
and more uh less and less forgiving
let's say um because more and more bad
things can happen as we move outwards.
So, which fault model are we going to be
spending most of our time on in this
class? Um, mostly we're going to be
looking at the omission model.
So, in the omission model, not as many
bad things can happen as in the fully
general Byzantine model. It's true, but
it's still a model where a lot of bad
things can happen. And so it's still
pretty hard to implement protocols and
algorithms that assume the omission
model because those protocols and
algorithms still have to tolerate a lot
of bad things.
In fact, there are a lot of things that
one would like to be able to do in
distributed systems that are impossible
to do in the omission model.
Uh and so that kind of leads us into the
topic uh that I want to talk about next
which is which we was was hinted at a
moment ago. um uh which is a classic
thought experiment in distributed
computing called the two generals
problem. Uh I don't know if I'm going to
have time to talk about it entirely
today. Uh and we're going to pause and
do a quiz question. Uh but if I have
time after the quiz question, we'll
start to talk about the two generals
problem. So here's our quiz question.
and we'll wait a few minutes for that.
Yeah. So if on your first attempt the
form it's closed. Uh try now.
We'll give it maybe one more minute.
Okay.
So, in the time that we have left,
and I don't know if we'll get through it
all, but let's let's give it a shot. Um,
let's start to talk about this this
classic thought experiment of the two
generals problem.
Um, so this is old. It dates back to the
70s.
And uh in the original setup um it
actually wasn't about two generals. It
was about two uh groups of organized
criminals. And uh somehow it became it
morphed into the two generals problem in
the in the intervening years. Uh anyway,
the idea is the following. Um,
so suppose we have two generals with
their armies,
General Alice and General Bob, and
they're each encamped on a hill
uh with their armies.
And in the valley in between, uh, the
enemy is encamped.
So Alice and Bob know that neither one
of them on their own is strong enough to
attack the enemy. But if they work
together, then they outnumber the enemy.
So, they'd like to both attack the enemy
at the same time.
The only problem is that they're too far
away to communicate uh via smoke signals
or anything like that. So, the only way
to send a message is to send a messenger
through the valley uh who will sometimes
be captured by the enemy and sometimes
not.
And if a messenger is captured, then the
message that they're carrying is lost.
Um, so let's walk through what would
happen in the best case scenario where
no messages are lost and everything goes
fine. Um, so let's say that Alice wants
to attack tomorrow at dawn. So she sends
a message over to Bob. Um, and you know,
we could draw it with a lamport diagram
if we wanted to. Uh, uh, but let's just
talk about it uh, informally for now. So
Ellis sends a message to Bob saying, "I
want to attack tomorrow at dawn."
And so let's say Bob gets the message.
Um, and at this point, Bob knows that
Alice has proposed to attack at dawn.
So at this point, should Alice go ahead
and attack
right? No, because Alice doesn't know
that Bob got the message, right? She has
no way of knowing at this point uh
whether her message got lost or not. So,
what should happen? Well, Bob should let
Alice know that he got the message. So
Bob should respond and say, "Okay, got
it. Let's attack tomorrow at dawn."
Cool. Okay. So suppose that exchange of
message happens and that message gets
through and it's received and delivered
on Alice's side. Now Alice knows that
Bob got her message.
Now is it safe for Alice to go ahead and
attack at dawn?
What do you think?
No.
Yeah. Why not? Because well, Bob doesn't
know that his acknowledgement got to
Alice, right? And he knows that if Alice
doesn't see an acknowledgement, she
won't attack. So Bob can't attack
because he can't be sure that Alice is
going to attack too. Um, so here's what
our exchange of messages looks like so
far.
So Alice sent a message
and we can draw it in a lamp diagram
style.
So Ellis said
attack
at dawn.
you in?
And then let's say Bob got that message
and sent back.
I'm in.
Attack at Dawn.
Okay.
But as we've just established,
that's not enough, right? Because even
if Alice gets this confirmation from
Bob,
Bob doesn't know that this message
arrived over here. So Bob doesn't know
that Alice will attack for sure, right?
Because Bob knows that Alice won't
attack unless he confirms, right? And
Bob can't attack unless he knows that
Alice is going to attack. Okay. So,
well, Bob could let Alice know that that
he got the message. Um,
or excuse me, Alice could let Bob know.
Okay, it's on.
But does that solve the problem? No,
because Alice doesn't know that that
message got through, right? So, Bob
could act that message as well, but of
course, he doesn't know if that act was
received. So, can anyone think of a way
to fix this?
So it turns out that in the omission
model, it is impossible for Alice and
Bob to ever attack and know that the
other one will attack because it would
require sending an infinite number of
acknowledgements of acknowledgement.
ments of acknowledgements and so on.
So
we can say in the omission model
which is what this uh this fable is an
illustration of because messages could
get lost.
In the emission model is impossible for
a general to know
that the other will attack.
This is one of many fundamental
impossibility results in distributed
systems and it applies in any setting
where there are two parties that are
communicating and failures of
communication can occur.
So are there any workarounds?
So one workaround is that before they
went and camped out on these different
hills, Alice and Bob conferred in
person, right? And they agreed on a plan
of attack.
So that is what philosophers and
logicians call common knowledge.
So we'll say workaround
for the two generals problem.
Uh make a plan in advance.
So this is an example.
of common knowledge which is actually a
technical term.
So we say so common knowledge uh
formally defined um we say
that there is common knowledge
of some piece of information.
P
when
Everyone knows P.
Everyone knows that. Everyone knows P
and so on.
and so on infinitely.
So if there were some predetermined
attack time that was common knowledge
between Alice and Bob, uh then that
could work. That would be an example of
having common knowledge. Somebody asked
in chat, "But what if the plan changed?"
Yeah. So then they wouldn't have common
knowledge anymore. So that wouldn't
work.
Are there any other workarounds
that we could do here?
Well, so although it's impossible to
solve this problem
in practice, it is possible for the
generals to increase their confidence
that the other general will attack.
Right?
So maybe one way to do this is would be
for Alice to send a whole bunch of
messages
uh at regular intervals all saying
attack at dawn, right? Sooner or later,
let's say one of them gets through and
Bob sends an act and at that point Alice
can stop sending messages. So if Alice
receives the act, right, and then
Alice's messages stop coming through,
uh, then over time, Bob will gradually
grow more certain that Alice receives
the act, right? That Alice received the
act because the longer he goes without
getting a message from her that says
attack at dawn, the more sure he can be
that she stopped sending them on
purpose. Now it could be the case that
she is still sending them and all of
them are getting lost, right? So he
still can't be certain. Uh but the
probability of that uh we're assuming
that that probability would be low and
would get lower as time goes on.
So
even though
this is impossible
in general, there are workarounds uh
that make it uh kind of practical to
exchange messages and and know that not
or not necessarily know but be
reasonably confident
uh that the that the other participant
got the message.
questions about this.
All right, it doesn't look like there's
any questions. Uh, so brief
announcement. Um, if you're uh if you're
taking the class, um,
let me switch back to
uh another window here. One second.
So, those of you who are taking the
class for credit, um this is our
schedule for the next few days. Um
so, uh we didn't get through all this
stuff today. Um but um uh we have
lectures uh Wednesday and Friday. Um
Monday, next Monday is our pause for
breath day, which we're probably going
to need because I don't think we're
actually going to get through all this
stuff in these days. And then next
Wednesday is our midterm. So I haven't
talked very much about what the format
of the midterm is uh yet because uh I've
still been figuring it out myself. Uh
but I promise that I will have an update
on that soon. And uh um so assignment
two is due uh this week on Friday. Um
and then you have a little bit of a of a
homework break um for a week uh which
should allow you some time to study for
the midterm. Uh so the midterm is
obviously going to be completely online.
Um and we'll talk soon more about the
the format of it as soon as I get that
figured out. Uh that's it. Uh any
questions about that briefly before we
have to wrap up?
How long will the midterm be? Uh if you
mean like in terms of number of
questions. Um so it's going to be I I
don't know the exact number of questions
but it's going to be designed so that it
can be reasonably done uh during class.
um even barring things like internet
problems. So, uh it'll be
uh if anything, it'll be shorter than
one that I would normally do for an for
an in-class in-person midterm. Um as far
as uh the details about how exactly um
it'll be implemented, I don't know the
answers yet. So, um I'm I'm trying to
work that out right now. So, I will
update you on those things as soon as I
can.
All right. Thanks everyone. See you next
time.